- Thank you.
My name's Pete Di Stefano.
I'm with SolarWinds.
I'm here with Ryan Lauer from Paciolan.
We are going to spend some time today
kind of taking you down
their cloud journey.
So, let me quickly take
you through the agenda.
We got industry challenges,
artificial intelligence,
Paciolan's overview, generative AI,
the cloud journey of Paciolan,
artificial intelligence,
AI, agentic AI.
Okay, I just wanted to make sure
we got a few words in there about AI
because I know we want to
kind of get the jump
on all the people here
because nobody out here
has talked about AI yet.
So, I thought we'd come out
there and start with that.
Seriously,
we both probably talk a
little bit about AI later on,
but we are going to take you
through Ryan and his company's journey.
But before I do that,
I want to talk a little bit
about industry challenges
that we're all facing.
Now, I'm not going to read this list,
whether it's troubleshooting
or root cause analysis,
visibility gaps.
If I add up all your challenges
that you're all facing today,
one of them is time.
Time when things are not going right,
time when things are down,
and really, what does
that really boil down to?
It's the challenge of
delivering on services
in today's very complex environment.
So, I'm not sure what your
environment looks like.
You might be pure cloud,
you might be pure on-prem,
you might be some hybrid world.
I believe most of us are in
some type of hybrid environment.
Well, you're going to hear
a lot more about SolarWinds
and this concept of
operational resilience.
Well, resilience,
you guys who are working in industry,
it means when something goes wrong,
how quickly, how resilient can I be?
How quickly can I get up and running?
Well, operational resilience
is the concept of I know
something is going to go wrong.
I might have a bad change
that causes an issue.
I might have a bug in some software
or a system that goes down.
How can I plan for the fact
that things are going to happen?
How do I plan for when there is an issue,
I can continue to deliver
a level of service
without any impact to my business?
That's what our entire company,
our portfolio is about,
is helping you become
operationally resilient.
Now, our goal is to help you
and your people be able to
be operational resilience,
and that's with the
workflows, the processes,
and of course the
technologies that you're using
to support and observe
your IT environment.
Now, instead of me talking about that,
what I'd like to do
is we're going to have Ryan talk about
why time is of the
essence within his company
and how important, how critical it is
to deliver on service for
the success of his company.
So Ryan, why don't you take
us through who Paciolan is.
- So, here at Paciolan, what
we do is live event ticketing
and most of our clients
are in the college athletics arena.
So, what we do is we provide people
the ability to buy the tickets,
scan 'em at the stadium when they come in.
And there's different times
that we have traffic spikes
and that's basically
centered around the time
that we do on-sales for our clients
when we have people
coming into the stadiums
and scanning and coming
into the the stadium
and stuff like that.
- All right, so especially
this time of year,
I'm so thankful
that Paciolan was willing
to spend time with us,
'cause this is really
the bread and butter part of their year
and they're spending time with us.
So, thank you for that.
Let's kind of go through a
little bit of this journey
that Paciolan has gone through.
Let's start with just talking about...
Tell us about your IT environment.
I know you're hybrid, right?
- Correct, we have a couple
of Kubernetes clusters,
some in EKS, some on-premises,
and we have different AWS
architecture that also works
with some of our other
on-premises architecture.
- Okay.
So, I talked about
challenges just a moment ago.
I talked about things like root cause,
getting to the root cause quickly,
or how do I understand, do
have visibility to everything.
What are some of the historical
challenges Paciolan has had?
- So, when we started to containerize
and move all of our on-premises services
to a microservice architecture
in either EKS or on-premises Kubernetes,
some of the challenges we
found were we weren't sure
how some services would
interact with other services
and how they would act being containerized
instead of being, say,
in a Beanstalk or an EC2.
And what we did is we
installed the SolarWinds APM,
which helped us kind of get an insight
into how our services were
interacting with other services,
any kind of network latencies
or anything like that that we could find,
SolarWinds would show
us in their dashboards.
And then, that way we could
better tune our services.
We can set more realistic
limits and requests
based on what we see in our traffic.
- All right, so you've been using,
they've been using SolarWinds for a while
and there was a variety
of different tools,
but what was the new approach
you guys decided to use
and why?
- So, the APM was relatively new.
We kind of wanted to see
how everything would
interact with each other
as we were doing our migrations.
And then, when we do those big on-sales
or we have those big football Saturdays
where people are coming into the stadium
and scanning their tickets,
we wanted to be able to have insight
into how all of those services were acting
as well as our infrastructure,
so that we could see
CPU, memory, disk writes,
network, that kind of stuff
with our infrastructure
as well as the APM.
And then, also show all
of our AWS infrastructure
behind that single pane of
glass that SolarWinds gives us
so that we can sit behind
and look at these dashboards
and, say, we have a dashboard for SREs,
we have a dashboard for
development, for customer service.
Everybody watches their own dashboards
to be able to tell how
their services are reacting,
what kind of impact they're seeing
in their different areas.
- [Pete] Yeah, would you
mind telling the folks
what you had to do this morning?
- So yeah, this morning,
there's a couple big on-sales.
I know bowl selections are coming.
So, as I was watching the AWS keynote,
I was monitoring our on-sales.
Our sister company SIDEARM also
has early signing day today,
which is a big day in college athletics.
A lot of people are coming to the sites
just to see, you know,
who their colleges are picking
from the high school students.
And what we like to see is
how everything's operating,
and the SolarWinds
dashboards gives us that,
as well as setting up alerts
for some of those key
services and bottlenecks
that we've seen in the past.
We set up alerts
so that if we kind of see
something going wrong,
we're notified well before
our clients are calling us,
saying, "Hey, our systems are down."
- All right, thanks.
So, you've been an AWS
customer eight, nine years?
- Yeah, it's been about eight years,
I believe.
- Yeah, so, you know,
what have been the benefits
of now leveraging AWS,
'cause you guys migrated
from on-prem into the cloud.
Why AWS?
- So, AWS gives us the
ability to scale quickly.
If we're noticing that our
nodes are high on memory or CPU
from one of our dashboards,
we can go ahead and scale up.
If we notice our services
or maybe a service is
getting bottlenecked,
the request time isn't
where we want it to be,
we can always scale those services up.
And AWS and EKS allow us to do that
whereas on-prem it's a little more,
requires more planning to add
hardware into our clusters.
- [Pete] All right. So, monitoring.
You monitor a network,
you monitor a database,
you monitor an application.
Why observability?
- Just so that we can get
a jump on any issues we see
and we can better plan
for the upcoming on-sales
for the upcoming football seasons.
We know where our services are at
and even though we do a lot of our changes
in the off time during the summer,
come full load and even though
we do load testing, you know,
sometimes it just doesn't
react the same way
as live traffic.
So, what we like to do is
those first couple weeks,
we're all on a call,
we're watching our dashboards
and making sure we're all
talking to each other,
making sure that everything
is working the way we want it to.
And if we start to see issues,
we can make adjustments
right then and there.
And SolarWinds gives us
the ability to do that
with the real-time metrics
for either our APMs
or Kubernetes clusters, EC2s,
databases, stuff like that.
- All right. Well, thanks.
So, first of all,
I didn't mention AI once
through his whole...
But don't get me wrong,
I'll get that in here in
the next couple of minutes
before we're done.
And by the way, if you
do have any questions,
I've just got a couple more slides,
we'd like to open it up
if you have any questions
for Ryan or for myself.
So, I do want to talk a
little bit about SolarWinds
and our overall platform across the board.
On the left, you'll see our
observability offerings,
and I say Monitoring and Observability
'cause monitoring is a key element.
It's a foundational
element of observability.
But if you truly want to understand
the state of your system,
you need to look at all
the elements together.
And as Ryan said,
when you have multiple teams
being able to look and have
the same single source of truth
and to be able to look at the impact
that a database or an
application or an infrastructure
is having on the overall system
and looking at it together on a platform,
that's why we've built out
a full-stack observability platform.
And with SolarWinds,
you can do that from SaaS
or you can do it from on-prem, your call.
Full stack.
Wherever your stack is running,
you can run it SaaS or on-prem.
We've included incident response
to really connect the dots
between all of the things that
are happening in real time
and communicating to the people
that need to solve that problem.
And then, to complete the lifecycle,
all integrated into our
service management offering.
So, whether it's your
help desk, your problem,
your change management,
your incident response,
and your monitoring and
observability at SolarWinds,
we believe these three things
together can help your people,
your processes and workflows,
and help you with your technologies
to be operationally resilient.
Now, just to give you an idea on the...
Whoops, sorry.
To give you an idea, when
I talk about full stack,
when I talk about observability offerings,
we're talking about your
networks, your infrastructure,
your applications, your user experience.
To not understand the user's perspective
of availability and performance,
you're not looking at the whole picture.
It doesn't matter how
many green lights you have
in your network operating center.
What matters is the user's
perspective of performance.
So, being able to look at
all that stuff collectively
is really important,
as well as your databases, security.
And by the way, all built
on a common platform
that delivers dashboards and alerting,
intelligent alerting systems.
And yes, machine learning
engine, generative AI,
and newly announced agentic AI.
We'd love you to come by our booth, 1380.
Let our guys show you some of the stuff
that Ryan and Paciolan is doing
and some of the other things
that SolarWinds can bring to the table
so you can understand
how your company could be
operationally resilient.
Any questions for Ryan or myself?
Thank you for taking the time.